Breaking news.
Police say at least five
people are dead
after a shooting
at a Colorado Springs nightclub.
The shooting happened
just before
midnight at Club Q
It's an LGBTQ nightclub.
Another 18 people
were injured in that shooting,
according to authorities.
Colorado Springs
police say they have a suspect in custody
That person is currently being
treated at an area hospital
Moving forward,
we have
numerous homicide detectives on scene.
They'll be processing the scene.
The scene is going to take some time
to get through.
So we will be here for many, many hours
to come.
So far, police have declined
to speak about a possible motive,
but the club put out this statement.
Club Q
is devastated
by the senseless attack on our community.
Our prayers and thoughts are
with all the victims
and their families and friends.
We thank the quick reactions
of heroic customers
that subdued the gunman
and ended this hate attack All right.
Joining us now is Chief Charles Ramsey.
CNN senior law enforcement
analyst and former Washington, D.C.
police chief.
Good morning to you, Chief.
So the nightclub
calling it a hate attack.
We don't know if that exactly is the case
right now.
There is a suspect in custody,
but what are your first thoughts
knowing that this happened?
A deadly shooting happened inside
a gay nightclub?
Well, first of
all, the
police are wise not to release
a motive at this point in time.
It's too early in the investigation.
They've got a lot of work
that they have to do.
They have to interview witnesses.
They have to interview the suspect.
There's just a lot of work
that needs to be done.
This could be just an argument
that got out of hand
and wound up resulting in gunfire.
It could be a hate crime,
could be a variety of things.
But five dead is tragic.
It's very unfortunate.
Another 18 people injured.
And I think it's important to remember,
we don't know whether those injuries
were gunshot wounds
or just
injuries sustained
when people are trying
to escape the scene.
So there's a lot of information
and it still needs to come out.
And she you know,
even though
it is too early, at some point
there is going to be a look
into the background of the suspect here.
Social media you look for.
Whether anything was said,
I mean, what are the clues?
What are the tip offs
besides the obvious that someone
might have said
something inside the club
before the attack?
Well, obviously,
they may have said
something before the attack
and you mentioned something
very important,
and that is the person's
social media footprint.
You know what does that look like?
If they made threats before, you know,
is there information
that would lead them down a path
that would take them to an actual motive?
Were they involved with
somebody in the club and that person
was injured as a result of the up
the shooting?
I mean, there's just
a lot of pieces of the puzzle
that still need to be put together.
That's what investigators
are doing right now.
Fortunately,
they do have this person in custody
so they don't have to worry
about a larger threat beyond
just what took place in the club.
And they will get more information
as time passes.
I don't know
the extent of the individual's injuries.
And if he can be interviewed
at this point in time
or even if he's willing to cooperate.
But certainly
they'll be
getting as much information as possible
and following up with a news conference.
Yeah.
Again, a lot that we don't know here,
but I did
look online
club Q is an adult gay and lesbian
nightclub.
Again, five people have been killed
in the shooting there in Colorado.
Springs and at least 18 people injured.
So, of course, we'll stay on top of this
and bring you back.
Chief Charles Ramsey,
if there is more to talk about,
we appreciate you
joining us this morning.
Thank you so much. Thank you.